فيسبوك وانستغرام تعيدان حسابات ترامب
والماسكي يسميه السيد تغريده
وعشرات الفنانين الى الرياض لتكريم طلال
مداح اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
تناولنا من ايام المفاوضات الجاريه بين
فريق ترامب وشركه متعب بخصوص اعاده تفعيل
الحسابات واللي من خلالها طالب فيها محامي
ترامب بالنيابه عنه مساء اعاده تفعيل
حسابات الرئيس الامريكي السابق على فيسبوك
وانستغرام وكمان طالب اجتماع فوري للشركه
لمناقشه الطلب واتخاذ قرار عوده ترامب
للمنصه من بعد حضور دام عامين من بعد
احداث الكعبه في 20 21 واللي انحضر بعضها
ترامب من على اغلب المنصات الجديد اليوم
انه شركه متى اتخذت قرارها ونشرت مذكره
عنه بانها تعليق حسابات ترامب باسوار
حمايه جديده اللي يرجع تكرار الجرائم اما
مضمونها فقالت الشركه ان هم لا يريد انه
يعيق طريق النقاش المفتوح
الديمقراطي وخصوصا عند المجتمعات اللي
بتشهد انتخابات ديمقراطيه مثل امريكا وانه
لازم يكون الجمهور قادر على انه يسمع اللي
بيقولوه السياسيين ايش ما كان علشان
يقدروا ياخذوا القرارات الصح وقت
الانتخابات وانه تعليق حسابات ترامب انتهى
ولكن انه راح يخضع لمعايير وقوانين متى
مثله مثل اي مستخدم اخر وراح يكون فيه
عقوبات مشدده في حال تكرار اللي صار في 21
او في سنه 21 وكان رئيس مثل الشؤون
العالميه كمان غرد وقال انه انتهى قرار
تعليق حسابات ترامب وانه الحظر اللي كان
في 20 21 راح وانه تقييم الظروف الحاليه
استنادا لسياسه اداره الازمات الخاصه فيهم
وامه ترامب فكانت تردد فعله كالعاده بحساب
الخساره والربح واكيد هو شايف انه عدم
وجوده في اي من الصامت خساره فكتب على
منصه السوشي لانه فيسبوك خسر مليارات
الدولارات من قيمته من وقت ما تم حظر
الرئيس المفضل في امريكا وطبعا بالرئيس
المفضل ترامب هنا بيقصد نفسه ولازم هذا
الشيء ما يتكرر ثاني مع اي رئيس خلال
ولايه او اي شخص ما بيستحق العقاب بحسب
كلام ترامب وشكر منصه التروت سوشيال اللي
كان اطلقها من بعد الحظر على المهمه اللي
قامت فيها في الفتره الماضيه وقال انه
بتشهد نمو مذهل ومستقبل غير محدود اما عن
عوده ترامب لمنصه تويتر اللي كان لهم ماسك
شال الحضر عنه فيها من 19 نوفمبر زي ما
بتتذكره مشاهدينا فما في اي تعليق بهذا
الخصوص وحتى الان ترامب لم يستخدم هذا
الحساب ولم يغرد حتى الان طيب للمزيد عن
عوده حسابات ترامب الى من الصاد التواصل
نتحدث مع الكاتب والباحث السياسي بالشهر
الجرار
اهلا فيك معانا هل نعتبر
الحسابات بعد في متى بعد عوده حسابات او
حساب ترامب في تويتر انتصار لترامب
من حيث المتابعه كمشاهدين على الاقل وليس
بالضروره كابتخذين مواقف سياسيه مع ترامب
او ضد العوده لان النقاش سيكون ممتع اكثر
تكون سريع اكثر وخاصه في هذا التوقيت
الحساس هذا توقيت فيها فضائح سياسيه
بامتياز في المشهد السياسي الامريكيين
لاحظ قضيه الوفاق المسربه المعايير
المزدوجه التي طرحها الاعلام
المسربه
كان عنده همم وجده لديه وسائق يعني انه
سريه للغايه موجوده لديه هذه الوثائق كان
لازم تسلم للبيت الابيض لكن في نفس الوقت
الان بايدينا اتضح انه عنده كمان هو وثائق
ايضا سريه موجوده في بيته يعني
نعم هو فقط ليس في كراج منزله في داروه
وليس فقط ابان خدمته كنائب للرئيس وانما
ايضا عندما كانسر عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي وهذا هذه فضيحه مركبه بحد ذاتها
لانه ليس من صلاحيات على الاطلاق
التعامل مع هذه الوثائق السريه خارج
في داخل
نعم
بتقول انه بيحدث الامر مع بيضه ما بنشوف
نفس المعايير يعني مطبقه لا يهاجم بيضا
بنفس الحجم يعني
صحيح والاعلام هو المشكله الكبرى هي
الاعلام كيف تعامل الاعلام الامريكي سواء
التقليدي او الجديد اللي هو السوشل ميديا
في هذه الفضاء المتتاليه حتى الان ماكس
نائب الرئيس الامريكي يعني بكل السجالات
اللي كانت بينه وبين الرئيس ترامب واللي
لها علاقه في قضيه حظر التمر
في الانتخابات السابقه ايضا وقع في نفس
المقبض
العثور عليها همم في منزله المساله الان
هو هذه العوده
يزلها
ويتخذ القرار بشانها الرئيس السابق
من معايير سياسيه وتجاريه ايضا من الاحيان
الربحيه
هذه مساله تعليم استثمار وليس فقط كم منبر
اعلامي بالتالي تجدين الفارق كيف تتعامل
مع موضوع العوده لتويتر وهو ايضا كانت له
بعض الاراء ايذاء الم النار
كيفيه اتخاذ القرارات يعني تقريبا هو
يحاول ان يبقي على مسافه بيني وبين الى
هناك حتى ما طرح اسم مصر للترشح للرئاسه
الامريكيه وهذا لا بعيده على الاطلاق في
عالم السياسه الان في امريكا كما جاء
ترامب من خارج الاوصاف
السياسيه التقليديه همم لما لا هناك من
يقول لماذا لا يكون الامر كذلك بالنسبه
الولايات المتحده فالامر بعيد عنه
بس ماسك اصلا اعلن الدعم وليد اللي هو
حاكم فلوريدا يعني انه لو ترشح للرئاسه
[موسيقى]
اوباما الرئيس اصلا الولايات المتحده
عندما وضع مكافاه عمليه كبرى لمن يثبت انه
يظهر شهاده الميلاد والان بالنسبه لمصر
ولد في جنوب افريقيا وبالتالي هذه المساله
همم
من ناحيه القانونيه ولكن اصبح جزءا من
لعبه السياسيه الامريكيه لانه الان يقوم
ب-ضحالات كثيره خطيره هو فضحا ااه امور
تتعلق بكبد نايتين والان قضيه التسريبات
ولكن من يطالب ان يفرج عن الوثائق الخاصه
بي
وهذه الفضيحه الجنسيه العالميه التي طالت
العديد
من الملفات السريه في التويتر وكيف تعامل
تويتر معها وكيف كان عنده اجنده ليبراليه
بحسب ما بيقول الى الماسكو عنده استعداد
انه يستمر في هذه اللعبه وهذا ممكن يؤثر
طبعا في اي انتخابات على العموم احنا
بنشكرك على هذه المداخله كان معنا الكاتب
والباحث السياسي بشار جرار اللي ينضم
الينا هذا واشنطن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
وبما انه دخلنا في سيره تويتر وال الماسك
فلازم نتكلم عن احدث اخباره فهو من وقت ما
استلم تويتر وهو متحفنا صراحه بالتغريدات
والردود والقرارات واليوم الموضوع مختلف
فجاه ادهش متابعينه بتغيير اسمه على تويتر
هذا الاسم بالتحديد لانه ماسك بوجه الدعوه
قضائيه رفعها عليه مستثمرين تسلم من 2000
2018 بسبب تغريد تتكلم فيها عن خصخصه شركه
تسلا وتم التهامه وبعدها باطلاع في السوق
وكانت بدايه الجلسات او بدات الجلسات
المحاكمه في القضيه يوم الاثنين و خلال
الجلسه محمل مستثمرين طلعت منه لسان او هي
مقصوده او كان قصدي يتمسخر ما احنا عارفين
طبعا يعني الله اعلم بالنوايا المهم
المحامي قال الماسك مستر تويت تويت
انه التفكير هذا او التغيير هذا مؤقت لا
لانه يبدو انه المورط نفسه فهو من بعد ما
غير اسمه غير همم غرد انه هو غير اسمه الى
مستر تويت وتويتر مو راضي يسمح له الان
يرجع لي اسمه الحقيقي مره ثانيه
[موسيقى]
الم من جديد تصدر فيلم الخلاط بلس واللي
بيعتبر اول عمل سعودي من انتاجنا فليكس
قائمه الافلام ال 10 الاكثر مشاهده في
السعوديه خلال الاسبوع الاول من عرضه كان
الخلاط خلص من ضمن قائمه اكثر 10 افلام
مشاهده
فليكس على مستوى العالم وسجل مليون
و500,000 او اكثر من مليون و500,000
مشاهده
[موسيقى]
مين اللعب بليسك
فيلم الخلاط مثل ما قلنا اول عمل سعودي من
انتاج نتفليكس بالتعاون مع شركه تلفاز 11
وهو اول عمل للمخرج السعودي فهد العماري
في بطوله عدد من نجوم السعوديه مثل عبد
العزيز الشهري وابراهيم الحجاج
وغيرهم وبيقدم الفيلم خلال ساعتين حكايات
واحداث متنوعه عشان كده تم تسميته الخلاط
تكون قصص متنوعه وبتجمع مشاعر وتفاصيل
مختلفه وفي اربعه حكايات مبنيه على مبدا
الحيله وبيستخدم الفيلم مثل العربي القديم
اللي يعبر عن هذه الحيل وهي او المثل هو
من كان لديه حيله فل يحتال
عن كواليس واجواء فيلم الخلاط كلاسين نظم
الينا من الرياض منتج الفيلم محمد
القرعاوي اهلا فيك معانا محمد كيف حالك
والف مبروك على هذا النجاح
كيف حالك انا الحمد لله تمام انت احكي لي
عن مشاعرك لما شفت انه الخلاط في العشر
الاوائل على مستوى السعوديه وبعدين العشره
الاوائل على مستوى العالم
يعني والله الحمد لله
في خلاط حاليا يعني بين تعب وسعاده وفخر
باللي بكل احد شارك في العمل بصراحه الحمد
لله سعيد جدا فخورين همم يعني تفاجئنا
باول كم ساعه من عرض
الفيلم على المنصه صار رقم واحد في
السعوديه فطمنا الحمد لله الذي يوصل له
يعني صدى عالمي بعد خلال اول اسبوع صار من
التوب تن الافلام الغير الانجليزيه في
العالم فالحمد لله ان العين على العمل
والعين على الصناعه كلها فخورين جدا جدا
بالالف الشخصي اللي اشتغلوا على هذا
المشروع جيش كامل
لمحمد
من فريق الانتاج الى الممثلين الى الكتاب
الى المنتجين يعني كانت خليه نحل وكان جيش
يعني الحمد لله فخورين باللي صار واللي
سوينا احنا همم واحنا من الاشياء في
الفيلم انه همم كميه الممثلين او النجوم
اللي موجودين في كثار وكنا انا حتى كنت
باقول لك قبل الهواء انه كلهم صار لهم
فتره بس شفناهم في هذا الفيلم تحديدا بشكل
مختلف كلهم وكانه كلهم ممثلين يعني
محترفين كيف تمت هذه الاختيارات وكيف تم
التعامل معاهم لانه حسيت كانه كلهم كده
كانه قفزوا درجات كثيره يعني في الاداء
يعني الحمد لله
في التلفاز 11 هو وجودنا بين كميه كبيره
من المبدعين اللي في شبكه حوالين من
السعوديه ومن الخليج خلال 10 سنوات اللي
فاتت عملنا كثير محتوى على اليوتيوب
تعاوننا فيه مع فنانين كثير في المنطقه من
ناحيه التعب ومخرجين ومنتجين وممثلين فكل
احد اشتغلنا معه عندنا عليه وكل مخرج
اشتغل مع ناس عيني عليهم اه الحمد لله
كميه زخم الاعمال السعوديه اللي جالسه
تطلع من كل المنصهات وعلى السنه المكان
مغمورين ولا ما حصلت لهم الفرصه ولا لسه
ما حد اكتشفهم يعني مسؤوليات هنا ومن اهله
مع هذه القدرات الحمد لله يعني كان يوتيوب
شو 22 حلقه من
الشعر ممثلين كثير الحين زعلانين ما لحقنا
يعني نظهر كل احد ونتعامل مع كل احد
خلاط بلاس بلاس ولا
يعني باذن الله بس يعني التسميه هذه اتوقع
عندك اجزاء ولازم نوق
فه اوكي طيب كنت بدي اسالك كمان دائما
يقولوا انه في اعمال سعوديه بتنعرض موجوده
بعد الاحيان يمكن زي اي مجال يعني في جيد
في الممتاز في العادي وهكذا الباب بيقول
انه همم طيب طولوا بالكم يا جماعه لسه ما
حنوصل للمستوى اللي نافس فيه على مستوى
عالمي انتم اليوم بتثبتوا العكس همم لو
العكس في هذا الكلام بتحس انه هذه كلها
مقولات احباطيه يعني حاجات انه ما تقدر
تنافسه على المستوى العالم هذا
يعني لما احد يقول ما تقدروا نفسه نقول
طيب يعني انتهى النقاش بس افهم جدا
مسؤوليه اللي على كل صانع افلام وصانع
محتوى انه لا اذا ما في ثقه في المحتوى
السعودي في السينما مثلا ولا في مكان معين
ولا في المنصات ولا في ناس تتكلم عن
المستوى طبعا الصناعه جديده ورح تاخذ وقت
وهذا الشيء ما ناخذه على انه احباط او
تثبيت لا هذا مسؤوليات لو تحدينا ابدا لما
الشخص يروح يشتري تذكره ويروح للسينما
واجب الحق علينا ان ما نعطيه كلنا كسرناه
افلام شيء ما يستاهل وقته ابدا ااه لكن
الحمد لله جاسمين نفهم الجمهور نفهم همم
يعني كسر نعرف افلام بشكل عام مش تلفاز
حتى صناعه السعوديه جالسه على نفسها
والمتابع السعودي ما شاف نفسه والمجتمع
ومواقف كثيره بشكل مستمر من زمان عن
الشاشه الكبيره فطبيعه تكون رده الفعل طلع
الاعمال كل عمل يبني الثقه بين المتابع
والمصانع الافلام والحمد لله يعني نفس
الوقت شفنا صطار
يعني خلال اربع اسابيع الحمد لله كان
الاول
طلعت اعمال الناس كلها جلسه بتتكلم عنها
الفتره هذه الاعمال السعوديه وعلى العموم
واضح ان الجمهور متعطش لانه كل واحد جالس
بيحضر وبيتفرج واضح انه حتى عالمين في
اهتمام بما انكم وصلتوا لقائمه اهم 10
افلام انا باشكرك جدا ودائما بتمنى لك
التوفيق محمد بكل اعمالكم ان شاء الله
شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
ليله تاريخيه في انتظار كل محبين الفنان
السعودي الراحل صوت الارض طلال مداح ليله
تكريم صوت الارض اللي راح تكون الاضخم
فنيه في العالم كان اعلن عنا سابقا رئيس
هيئه الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ واعتبر مشاركه
اي فنان فيها تكريم خاص لي الراحل ومن بعد
الاعلان عن ليله صوت الارض السابق
الفنانين للمشاركه فيها من قبل حتى ما يتم
تحديد موعد اليوم اللي راح تكون فيه وصل
عددهم الا عشرات الفنانين والفنانات من
مختلف الدول العربيه واما عن اليوم المحدد
فهو الاول من فبراير وكان رئيس هيئه
الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ نشر تغريده اكد
فيها على طرح تذاكر الحفله وقال انها ليله
التاريخ
وترحل صرخه
للتاريخي ولتكريم بعد 22 عاما على رحيله
ايقونه الفن السعوديه والعربي ورصيد عشقا
وحب تزايد في حياته وبعد رحيله
ولاننا في نهضه غير مسبوقه في عهد مولاي
خادم الحرمين حفظه الله و سيدي ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء قائدنا الملهم وعراب
رؤيه 2030 في بادره الهيئه العامه للترفيه
لتكريم صوت الارض طلع الماده
راجعون
اه راجع
عجوز
[موسيقى]
وبشكل يفوق الخيال ومن كل الوطن العربي
للمشاركه والحضور في عرس فني ضخم وفي ليله
لا تنسى عنوانها الوفاء لصوت الارض
حسب الفنان جورج وسوف الشائعات الاخبار
اللي تم تداولها مؤخرا حول اعتزاله وقال
انه راجع يغني من جديد
ابن وديع في السابع من يناير بعد عمليه
جراحيه في المعده سببت له مضاعفات النزيف
ادى الى الوفاه وكانت تمت مراسم وداع وديع
جورج وسوف في بيروت ومن بعدها تم نقل
جثمانه الى قريته يكفرون في سوريا
اللي كان مقرب جدا له ومدير اعماله وكمان
فهل راح يرجع يغني او لا والاجابه كانت
عبر بيان نشر مكتب الفنان جورج وسوف حسن
خلال الجدل اللي صاير وخلال البيان شكر
الوسوف كل اللي وقف معه في هذه المرحله
الاليمه اللي مر فيها واعتذر عن الغاء
مشاركته في كل الحفلات والمناسبات
والمهرجانات اللي مقرره خلال الشهر هذا
الشهر القادم ولفت في البيان انه اول
اغنيه راح يغنيها الفنان من بعد هذه
التوقف في اغنيه راح لابنه الراحل وديع
[موسيقى]
وفي منافسه بتعتبر من اشرس المنافسات في
عالم التكنولوجيا هي بين اي و اس واندرويد
تشغيل اللي بيعتبرون من اهم انظمه
الاستخدام على الهواتف المحموله بمختلف
انواعا واللي من وقت ما تم تاسيس
الاندرويد بدات المنافسه بين النظامين
ومقتصرت بس على الشركات فحتى الافراد
بتلاقي اللي معاه ايفون ما بيعجب النظام
الاندرويد وبيحط في عيب والعكس طبعا صحيح
اليوم يبدا انه هذه المنافسه او الحرب
الصامته ما زالت مستمره ففي معلومات
نشرتها صحيفه
الخوض ثلاث مواجهات جديده مع اندرويد اولى
المواجهات راح تكون عبر تطوير التطبيق
الخرائط الخاصه بابل اللي كانت طرحته في
2012 عيوب كثيره واخطاء والناس فضلت او
فضلت وقت خرائط اندرويد عليه ثاني
المواجهات هي عمليات البحث كلنا بيلجا في
عمليات البحث لجوجل اللي بيعتبر محرك بحث
افتراضي في ابل ويبدا انه ابل قررت تزيح
جوجل من عمليات البحث على اجهزتها ولكن
المعلومات الجديده بتقول انه في شركه
اسمها ابل سيرتش هذه السيرج وادي الشركه
مهمتها تسهيل عمليات البحث وبتعمل على
تطوير ميزاتها في كل مره بيطلب فيها
باستخدم او بيطلب فيها مستخدم ابل اي
مساعده من سري او اي وقت بيعمل بحث على
سبوت لايت اما الموجه الثالثه بين
النظامين ربما هي الاقوى فهي نظام
الاعلانات فالمعلومات المتداوله لانه
الشركات بتعتزم بناء شبكه اعلانيه جديده
بتسمح بعرض الاعلانات لمستخدم الايفون
بشكل مختلف وبيتجاوز ومن خلاله الطرف
الثالث او الصياد طيب مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا
ليه ختام حلقه اليوم ان يعود يلقاكم
الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله في حلقه جديده
من تفاعل الكم عطله نهايه الاسبوع سعيده
[موسيقى]